ااا مثابره شغف طموح انا اسمي هبه الشامي
وعمري 20 سنه انا مهندستكمبيوتر وبشتغل
فصيلته بلشت اسطي لما كان عمري خمس سنين
[موسيقى]
بلاش بلاش يصير عندي ضعف بالسماء
بيسبب خلل شوي بالتواصل مع الاخرين لان ما
فيك تسمعون منيح وهذا الشيء اكيد بعيد
شاركت من الايوبي بمشروع عصايفه كان هو
عباره عن
انجنيرنج فورجيت يعني عم بتحدث عن اهميه
الهندسه والتكنولوجيا بالحياه وكيف فينا
فيهم يساعدونا لا نطور من المجتمع ااااه
هناك تقسمنا لفراق تعرفنا على اشخاص
وخطر على بالي فكره الندى
[موسيقى]
فرنسى الاشاره يتواصلوا مع الاشخاص اللي
بيسمعوا بطريقه كثير سهله بيفتحوا
التليفون بيصور لغه الاشاره ولغه الاشاره
من خلال الكاميرا بتتحول لنص انجلش او
عربي عربي
[موسيقى]
شخص سليمان
كان دعم الاول لا ليه همم خاصه ماما هي
دائما همم بتشجعنا وبتقول لها انه اذا هلا
ما اشتغلت انه هلا الوقت اللي اكثر شيء
الانسان بيكون فيه
مثابر وهيك عنده هل الطاقه فهي دائما
بتشجعنا يعني ما في دوره ما بترجعني بتقول
لي روحي عليها حتى لو بدها تاخذ مني وقت
كثير يعني تعلمت منه قديش انه يكون عم
منظم وقته قديش انه اوقات يكون ما عندي
وقت غير لانه عن جد بس اكل ونام بس كون عم
باستمتع بها الوقت خلي كل شيء عم بعمله
بالدورات والشغل يكون شيء حلو بالنسبه لك
وهي اصلا همم خليتني اشارك بالمجتمع وتكون
جزء منه كثير صغير يعني انا اول ما بلشت
همم متوسط
يكون اجتماعيه
بالحياه اكثر
[موسيقى]
اللي كنت اقطع فيها كنت اعمل القشره اللي
بحبها مثلا
شيء نهار مثلا كنت كثير مزعوجه او هيك خلص
فينا اخذ بريك ما اعمل شيء فينا اعزف
بيانو اعمل الشيء اللي انا بحبه همم اذا
كنت كثير مضغوطه بالوقت شوف ااه ارتب
اولاويات اشوف شو احسن اعمله
بهالطريقه بخفف ضغط عن حاله بشكل كثير
كبير
[موسيقى]